ça y est ça suffit
conseils de la cible de la ciboulette il
nous faut des œufs de l'ail un petit peu
de là du chou de la farine et de l'eau
du sel et du poivre bien entendu un peu
de graisse de canard naturel alors pour
l'accompagner vous nous avez dit tout ça
on peut se poser la question c'est parce
que pour l'accompagner il y aura des
couteaux oui on verra ce qu'on veut
dessus après et puis le chou c'est pour
faire un légume un légume avec des
lardons après alors pour commencer la
bécasse j'imagine qu'il faut penser à sa
croûte
mais c'est pas difficile on prend 500 g
de farine oui on fait un puits voilà
pour 500 g de farine il faut à peu près
un verre d'eau non on va mettre d'abord
le sel alors il faut deux il faut du
salé oui il faut 200 g de sel gros de
gros sel alors beaucoup et bien 5G à peu
près
une cuillère à soupe alors on en met
quatre voilà après il faut 100 g de sel
fin ah c'est beaucoup moitié oui mais
c'est triste
c'est juste pour cuire la loi et qui
assaisonne bien
un verre d'eau
voilà
tout le monde sait que toutes les
farines n'étant pas pareil un verre
d'eau c'est avoir voilà mais c'est à
vous on va voir sentir au bout des
doigts mais là vous pouvez le mettre
franchement
rien que le blanc et voyez j'avais
oublié merci
je me demandais pourquoi vous aviez des
petits œufs alors qu'on est à la
campagne
voilà voilà elles sont bien jaunes très
bien alors maintenant
c'est là qu'il faut avoir la main assez
légère parce qu'il faut pas la remettre
ça se sent au bout des doigts
c'est pareil c'est une question de main
et la manie trop chaude ni trop froide
etc
voilà
il en faut un peu plus vous voyez là
justement
ça vraiment les recettes dans les livres
c'est pas la même chose que de le voir
faire
voilà ça y est elle va juste mélanger on
va pouvoir la laisser reposer j'imagine
c'est pas il faut toujours ce genre de
pâte qu'elle repose ça y est c'est bon
on va pratiquement
je crois que la pâte est finie là me
paraît très bien qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire on va la mettre de côté
la laisser repos et on va s'occuper de
la bécasse
et qu'est-ce qu'on va faire à cette
bécasse
alors est-ce qu'on peut faire comme vous
nous aviez montré précédemment je crois
avec un canard un colvert autrement dit
la frotté de résine et la plongée ah non
non non non
on va faire ça madame vous mettez les
ailes comme ça pour faire le corps oui
comme ça vous avez tout le temps dégagé
et vous faites ce que vous voulez là
voilà tout simplement tout simplement et
vous la vivez pas
la bécasse est plumée mais vous la
brûlez pourquoi faire pour faire brûler
les derniers duvet les derniers petits
poils qui restent pour qu'elle soit
beaucoup plus nette voilà dans les
jolies impeccable et qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire maintenant allons maintenant je
vais la saler et la poivrer voilà
bien évidemment d'abord du sel
juste un peu je remarque que vous ne
l'avez pas vidé c'est exprès
malheureusement
et après ça alors après ça je vais la
barder je croyais que vous la faisiez
revenir avant il me semblait que vous
m'aviez dit vous la faisiez revenir
avant non je me trompe peut-être
on l'a fait revenir à la Grèce
on va la faire juste doré un tout petit
peu
[Musique]
prendre couleur
voilà alors maintenant je vais la mettre
sur le centre de travail
voilà
qu'est-ce qu'on va lui faire maintenant
que je vais la garder voilà j'avais
brûle de l'étage
et sa tête vous allez lui mettre où
dedans
alors une petite barre de bien fine
reste là ma petite
voilà il faut surtout pas la ficeler
très bien pas la vidéo pas la ficelée la
voilà on va faire elle va dormir la tête
dans sa barre dépendance quoi je crois
que vous allez reprendre votre pâte non
maintenant on va faire c'est pas la
peine d'avoir un roule à pâtisserie
on va juste faire son nid dans la pâte
qui est jolie
voilà ça suffit
et on va lui mettre dedans
là on va bien
se couper voilà très bien très bien très
bien très bien parfait
voilà il est bien dans cette petite
croûte
là et au four et au four combien de
temps alors là au moyen un bon quart
d'heure un quart d'heure 20 minutes
selon la grosseur de la grosseur
[Musique]
voilà ça va te tenir très bien et si
vous avez préparé de la ciboulette aussi
la ciboulette va fondre sur le chou
brûlant oui et ça va donner bon goût ça
donne un bon goût c'est plus joli ça va
donner bon goût et maintenant on
s'occupe des croûtons alors comment
fait-on une belle tranche de pain
ça c'est la frotter là
et après on a fait chauffer notre poêle
avec de la graisse on fait dorer notre
tartine de pain dans cette graisse
très vite
de pain
et puis il nous restera plus qu'à aller
voir où on est la bécasse
on va la mettre sur notre plan de
travail parce que là il faut lui couper
la coque on dirait une momie
voilà elle est belle belle
en évitant de se brûler elle est cuite
juste à point
c'était la surprise quand on a ouvert la
coque comment serait la bécasse voilà je
vous rends le plat voilà alors
maintenant le plus dur on va la vider
on va enlever la tripes quoi et on va
mettre notre trip sur le père parce que
quand on a la chance de faire la ficelle
on le fait à la ficelle mais là et ben
voilà on est obligé de le faire comme ça
et alors en même temps on a dans notre
cheminée
notre concurrent qui est à vous chercher
donc ça va être chaud je vais prendre un
chiffon voilà
tout va bien j'espère
le voilà Maïté voilà alors qu'est-ce que
vous allez mettre dedans
que ça finisse de bien cuire bien grillé
là ça y est ça suffit
il n'y a plus qu'à présenter le plat
ça va mettre
l'application
nos légumes à côté peut-être quand même
et maintenant ça va être à vous
d'essayer ça n'est pas tellement facile
d'abord c'est pas tellement facile
d'avoir une bécasse mais on peut essayer
avec un autre un autre oiseau
indispensable d'avoir la bécasse on peut
essayer avec un perdreau éventuellement
ensuite la grande difficulté évidemment
c'est de ne pas rater la pâte qu'elle
est la bonne consistance et puis la
cuisson parce que certains aiment la
bécasse très rose mais ça valait et puis
d'autres l'aiment très cuite certains
aiment la tripe presque sanguine ou
Nantes d'autres la mieux vraiment très
cuite aussi
invité des amis comme ça vous aurez le
choix en fait si vous en avez qu'une à
deux et puis bon courage et à bientôt et
bon appétit et merci
[Musique]